all right full disclosure kind of thing
I know a lot of people have asked me why
don't review the walking dead here is
why because I talked about one episode
of the first season after first aired
then after that didn't really talk about
it more than I was like well I can't do
after season 2 wrapped up was like well
I can't do season 2 without of doing
season 1 and then season 3 came around
season 4 so now at this point it'd just
be weird to be like here's my season 5
review or 6 or whatever they're on
without doing videos on the seasons that
came before it so I didn't want that to
happen with fear The Walking Dead so I
figure I will keep on top of fear The
Walking Dead so I can review the seasons
as they come out so let's talk about
season 1 of fear The Walking Dead fear
The Walking Dead so fear The Walking
Dead is a series on AMC it's ultimately
a prequel to The Walking Dead it shows
civilization as it's still intact and
then slowly shows the zombies or walkers
start coming around and then
civilization starts falling but
ultimately fills in the gap of when Rick
Grimes was in his coma without actually
concentrating on Rick Grimes family it's
completely new family which is
interesting I wanted to see that because
in The Walking Dead it was a cricket
shot he wakes up from a coma and just
zombies everywhere neck deep in the
zombie apocalypse but before that was
probably very fascinating on the slow
reveal of how this started happening
people start getting sick people are oh
do they have the flu that sucks lockers
are like coming after people people like
it Billy is it's okay we're gonna get
your help man and that's ultimately what
fear The Walking Dead shows and that's
what I liked about it a problem with it
is that we are burdened with knowledge
we know very intimately the world that
these people are heading into but they
don't know that so when they start doing
stupid [ __ ] like it's okay we're gonna
get you help this Walker's like getting
towards them you're like dude runs gonna
bite you and you're gonna die turn into
one of them too but they don't know that
so it's natural that they would do that
because people in the world would
probably do that but to us they look
like idiots kinda like imagine going
back in time to the Year 1397 people are
like the world is flat we all knew this
to be factual you just be like I know
you're wrong you'll get there though
he's gonna gotta let them play it out
there were characters in the family of
life characters I did I'm he's smiley
from training day he actually does a
good job he's kind of the naive on he's
the hopeful is like oh we're all gonna
get better and civilizations is it's
fine without his wife was like
infinitely more badass than he is he
probably would have died
go I liked her she was very adaptable
you could tell early on she's like yeah
we're gonna have to kill or be killed in
this world even if it means killing
walkers like walkers are not human
beings anymore they come across this
family which the dude in there first
you're like you're a dam and later on
you're like yeah right you're just a
survivalist okay I get it and after that
you're like no you're still a dick
though I guess this is thing about The
Walking Dead is there are characters
that you gravitate towards cause you're
like oh I understand that person or I
would probably befriend that person
maybe no one in fear The Walking Dead's
not think I would not befriend anybody
and fear the walking dead he's one of
those people I wouldn't befriend him but
I would want him on my zombie apocalypse
chain which I guess that's what
inefficient zombie apocalypse team would
be filled with his people I wouldn't
like but I would need so I did like that
dynamic where it's like no and you don't
have to like the people you're thrown
into the mix with but you do need to
know that you need them and I'm gonna
tell you this dude was that close to
burning this entire show to the ground I
hated his guts I didn't like him as a
character he was whiny he was bratty
he's a heroin addict so he has junky
mentalities Orser I'm gonna kick the
habit but he never really does and it
would have been interesting to explore
something like that at a show like this
if it was done with just a better
character there was this one lady who
was severely injured and she needed
medicine she needed I think it was
methadone and the moms like no she needs
it more and there's bratty [ __ ]
like I need my medicine
um I'll [ __ ] you in fact I'm gonna let
you in on a little secret dude kissing
walkers is what makes them better go try
it right over there if you kiss her on
the lips she will get better trust me
it's deadly I would tell him that if I
was there really adds its fact and he
always had weird rubber suit Batman neck
he never turned his neck it was get this
weird look like why are you making that
look he did run across this one dude
when he was like captured in a Cell who
was a complete cartoon this dude's
dressed in a suit he's sleazy he's slimy
he knows how to throw a nickel out of
his pocket knowing that a quarter is
gonna come back to him do when they're
escaping he's really efficient like he
knows how to sniff out military people
he's running with the kid and he bucks
the kid against the wall and then the
military goes by is like all right he
goes really who are you
did you join the Navy SEALs and the
military ultimately paid for four years
of sleazebag college but doesn't matter
cuz that dude was super cool as
exaggerated as that dude was I'm glad he
was in as he made the show a little more
interesting even if he did come in the
last
it was - episode really started to shine
in the last one episode is in the end
fear the walking dead
I found it entertaining for what it was
it's not like you need to watch this to
actually get what's happening in The
Walking Dead because it doesn't tie
everything together you still not know
anything about where this virus actually
came from why it is you can stay with
The Walking Dead you'll be completely
fine if you want to see some insight as
to what led up to the Walking Dead this
isn't the insight to that I love the
fact that it's six episodes long because
it's short sweet marathon it you're done
if it was more than that if it was like
12 or 24 I'd be like not worth it six
episodes not too bad a question now is
where do they go with fear The Walking
Dead I guess it's up for a season two
but how and why that works I just don't
know I feel like the season finale of
season 1 ends off where ultimately
around where Rick Grimes wakes up in The
Walking Dead so I feel like it's just
the Walking Dead now with characters you
don't care about as much as you care
about The Walking Dead character it's no
longer the lead up and so I feel like
we're there the only thing they can
really do is let's say we're still a
little farther off from The Walking Dead
than I think instead of being like The
Walking Dead where they come across
civilizations and towns where people are
ultimately dickbag deer The Walking
Dead's ultimately going to be about
people who come across towns and
civilizations full of military people
who are dickbags I don't know we'll see
what happens in conclusion it's fear The
Walking Dead necessary no is it
entertaining yeah for 6hours sure I
enjoyed it cuz I like seeing
civilization fall to the zombie
apocalypse like gasps though it does
fill in that gap for me right guys so
fear The Walking Dead have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more